in a world of quarantine where no one is
allowed
outside and the only way to connect
online
is through the internet this is john
bailey
a professional voice-over artist you may
also know him as
my name is optimus prime auto parts
transform
and roll out and i fill in quite a few
times
for mr ryan reynolds depending on what
he's in the mood for you know
just what color pants he's wearing um
i've also fit in for chris hemsworth
quite a few times and
uh most recently leonardo dicaprio and
uh once upon a time in hollywood
but really he has actually subbed in for
them in trailers and movies
clearly we're not all voice over artists
with fancy setups
but we are trying to sound our best
whether it's on a phone call
or a zoom call even john here doesn't
sound perfect over zoom
without his fancy whisper room sound
booth how's it going
it's pretty good stuck inside like
everybody else nice
call back from my booth so i can get
better audio
so i asked john to share the best ways
we can sound better from home
he had three big tips all right does
that sound better
number one your environment you don't
want sound to bounce around
like the environment you're in right now
you're hearing a lot of this room echo
hello hello echo do you hear me
where in my booth you don't hear that
anymore because the sound absorbs into
it
john's best advice get some moving
blankets
some super professional voice actors
they don't even have a fancy dude
they're just using living blankets from
the hardware store downstream
the takeaway hard flat surfaces like
these
are your enemy you could get fancy
acoustic foam to hang on your walls like
the kind that john has
but choosing a room with a lot of soft
stuff uh rugs couches
things hanging on the walls will get you
close number two
your microphone when it comes to your
microphone
size matters the part of the microphone
that captures your voice is called a
capsule
the bigger the capsule the better the
sound i've been doing some testing and
if you're looking for something better
than your earbuds
try this one sure it's not as good as
john's thousand dollar professional mic
but the 130 dollar blue yeti does a
great job at producing warm clear audio
for video calls
it's not a solution for phone calls on
your smartphone it's best if you're at
your computer
it works with a mac or pc and its mic is
pretty much
plug and play though there are some
knobs on the back you need to know about
you can actually flip it onto a setting
that's more built for
voice only as opposed to picking up
other stuff
is it this one yep that's the one if you
work in a large echoey room like me
you can also turn the gain dial down to
reduce some of that environmental noise
there is one important no button trick
to remember though
that is all you have to do you make a y
shape bro all right hang ten
take your your 10 and put your pinky at
the mic and your thumb at your mouth
that's how far away from the mic you
should be yes if you have a high quality
microphone
maintaining that hang loose distance is
very important
but for smaller microphones you'll tend
to get better audio if it's closer to
your mouth
that's why for important calls i prefer
a headset like this
call center style this one is the
logitech zone wireless
which has a little arm that holds out
the microphone number three
your connection connection is obviously
very important you know if you have a
great setup great mic it doesn't matter
you have a shoddy connection
that's 100 true slow internet speeds or
a bad wi-fi signal can make you sound
terrible so for video calls a wired
connection
over an ethernet cable is best but if
that's not an option
sitting close to your router can also
improve the strength of your connection
you can also turn off your video to save
that bandwidth for audio
the service you choose also matters for
instance
the zoom video conferencing app
automatically suppresses
background noise and echo test your mic
in the app's audio settings
then click on advanced to turn up the
feature to aggressive or off
lastly using a wired headset like this
one can eliminate any bluetooth or
interference issues
and while all of these tips should help
you sound better
they probably can't transform you
into john rated pg-13 starts friday in
theaters everywhere
except that the theaters are closed